I was told that everyone who works at the tva
was created by the timekeepers that's ridiculous
they're all variants just like us they don't know
that welcome back everyone this is going to be my
marvel loki episode 3 video there were so many
easter eggs they finally revealed what's going
on with sylvie aka sylvie laufeydottir the loki
variant so we'll break everything down i'm doing
videos for all the episodes if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get everything
and we're doing a disney plus giveaway for
memberships all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave all your theories after what
happened at the end of the episode and obviously
careful for spoilers for everything that happened
during episode 3 if you haven't seen it yet
i'll start at the beginning of the episode and
we'll work our way through shot by shot talking
about easter eggs and wtf moments i'll number
these as we go along too just to stay organized so
starting with the title of the episode the episode
was titled lamentus which is a reference to the
planet that loki sent them to with that timepad
portal device but lamentus is also the latin verb
for lamenting something which is a reference to
both of them sort of revealing their backstories
and the differences in their upbringing to each
other on the train like loki lamenting frigga's
death in remembering his past in sylvie lamenting
her upbringing in the lack of frigga the fact that
she didn't have a frigga to help raise her at the
beginning of the episode over the recap they also
played more of that theremin music a lot of you
are also asking about that because the theremin
instrument is also where the doctor who theme song
comes from in the actual brand new version of the
theme song that they played over the credits
the green loki version of the marvel studios
logo actually sounded kind of like the doctor who
theme song mixed with the loki theme song there's
a lot of doctor who energy in the series just in
general too with the time keepers the time lords
gallifrey the big time citadel they're in here the
actual opening scene though is kind of a flashback
explaining some of the big twists and reveals
from hunter c20 during episode two there were a
couple things that she was shouting that sounded a
little confusing and this was them just answering
those questions and setting up a big reveal about
the tva itself that they made at the end of the
episode the fact that everybody that works at the
tva from the hunters people like mobius everyone
does not realize that they're all variants from
other timelines this also explains what's going on
with mobius there have been so many fan theories
about who he really is if he's secretly somebody
else but now they're basically saying that he's
just a guy probably from the 90s who became
a variant that they took like that's probably
why he's so obsessed with the 90s and jet skis in
particular because he created a nexus event during
the 90s became a variant and that's when they
plucked him out it sounds like the timekeepers
someone at the tva is altering their memories so
they don't remember but during episode 2 when they
found hunter c20 she kept saying it's real it's
real i want to go home and we basically find out
what that was a reference to in this opening scene
it was sylvie using her enchantment magic which
she later actually explained how it worked
spinning up an illusion based on a memory from
hunter c20s passed when she lived on earth
it was them inside this restaurant having
drinks pretending to be these old friends
sylvie trying to get the information out of her
where are the time keepers how do i find them
how many guards are there i love sofia dimartino's
performance as this female version of loki too she
has the same sense of timing that tom hiddleston
has which i think is important for the idea that
she is a loki varian they both feel like very
similar characters they have similar fighting
styles they have similar witty banter we'll get to
that part too there was a lot of homelander energy
going on during the episode with the two of
them together they have some real chemistry
and if you have not seen season 2 of the boys yet
you are in for something real special i also love
the way they play on the brain freeze joke like
do you actually realize what's happening it's
your synapses freezing briefly for a second and
you won't actually be able to recall that memory
until they unfreeze in the whole thing with the
time jumps like it seems like time jumps forward
suddenly in its night all of a sudden that's just
an example of silvie when she was talking about
what it's like for people who have really strong
minds like they're in there with me and sometimes
they start to figure out what's going on and
hunter c-20 was supposed to have kind of a strong
mind like she starts to figure out what's going
on a couple different times and silly has to cycle
to another version of the illusion but then they
do reveal what's actually happening and you're
back in the present of what was episode 2 with
her sitting there inside the rocks card just
manipulating her mind trying to find out about
the time keepers she tells her about the gold
elevators and the doors that we've seen in all the
trailers i actually thought that that was kind of
what was going on here based on the last couple
of trailers because i thought this person was
silvie in this part of the hallway also seems
similar to some of the other trailer footage
with ren slayer's character stepping through those
doors into this space that looks kind of like an
m.c escher painting so i'm assuming because
loki is wearing the same costume here like
he's wearing that same outfit that will actually
go past these doors within an episode or two
i don't know if it's from the finale it feels like
it's actually going to happen sooner than that
they're making so many big reveals so much quicker
than i would expect them to and i think we're all
expecting some big wizard of oz style reveal with
the time keepers they were kind of foreshadowing
that in episode 1 and episode 2 when loki's like
wait a minute you mean i'm going to get to see
the time keepers that's all he could talk about
and now that's all that sylvie can talk about too
making it to the time keepers so wouldn't be
a grand twist if the timekeepers themselves
aren't exactly what we think they are then they
actually confirm my theory about what's going on
with sylvie so i did a big sylvie explainer video
about how basically her whole plan here with the
time bombs trying to destroy the sacred timeline
create all these branches was basically to get
the tva to send all of its hunters every possible
person they could out to try and stop these nexus
events erase them before they became permanent
fully branching timelines but in doing so
leaving the tva itself extremely undefended
making it much easier for sylvie to break into the
timekeeper's vault here and that's basically what
she did this portal that she opens that loki then
follows her through is right back into the locker
room that they left from earlier in the episode
she finds out that her enchantment magic doesn't
work on these guards maybe there'll be a bigger
reveal for that later on why it didn't work
she erases some of them with their stun batons
that basically disintegrates them loki made the
joke about it melting people in episode two like
it's kind of like people are getting melted here
that's another call back to thor ragnarok with the
melting stick that the grandmaster use grossing
thor out like oh my god what's happening here
arloki grabs his daggers from hunter b-15's locker
where she threw them before the mission started
then they start fighting back and forth they
start training insults back and forth and fighting
physically they're supposed to be pretty evenly
matched even though she does acknowledge that
loki's magic is much more powerful than hers later
in the episode like i didn't have someone to teach
me magic like you did loki's super curious about
her but he also kind of wants to stop her because
that's the mission stop her stop the variant
ren slayer comes up on them also makes it seem
like she doesn't care what happens to either of
them like go ahead kill loki i don't care then
he portals both of them away and that's when they
wind up on lamentis one they're in the year 2077
so it's the not too distant future but lamentus
is a marvel reference for a planet in the cree
system that appeared during the annihilation
conquest storyline it's a planet where quasar
was where he found out about the annihilation wave
that was coming this big apocalyptic event that
was going to wipe out all life in the universe and
during the episode there is a giant apocalyptic
event that's happening sylvie says that it's
actually the worst of all the apocalyptic
events that he could have possibly sent them
to that were stored on that special time pad
basically it's a glorified mining colony in
cree territory increased space so a lot of
the characters the writing you see on walls the
signage all the graffiti that's all cree writing
so if you're a whiz with the cree language let
me know in the comments below if you could decode
any hidden messages in any of the graffiti or any
of the signage they kind of did something similar
during the mandalorian season 2 episode 1 with
all these easter eggs baked into this graffiti
that was on this giant wall this is probably one
of my favorite episodes so far just because of the
witty banter and the energy that they give off
with each other they have such good chemistry
tom hiddleston and sophia di martino playing
versions of loki each constantly trying to one-up
each other and then bonding over some of their
tragic history both of them have very tragic past
but at certain points their lives did diverge like
there are different aspects of their upbringings
that were very different the big mcguffin of the
episode though is the time pad itself like if we
recharge it we can totally get back to the tva we
can escape it kind of seems like all their tech
all the tva's tech runs on quantum energy just
based on the color coding the portal energy looks
very similar to iron man's time pad that all the
avengers left when they were going on their big
time heist i know there are a lot of people that
are wondering if the timekeeper citadel is inside
the quantum realm too i don't think that it is but
it's actually a pretty decent theory so if i see
more evidence for that i will do a video about it
the actual quantum city inside the quantum realm
is supposed to be completely different in the
comics like it's a completely different form of
life that lives down there it's not like a bunch
of regular humans running around but then silvie
explains her backstory and it's actually
pretty close to what i explained during my
lady loki video that i posted a while ago so i had
a link for that down in the description but the
idea was that she was born to lafay she was given
the loki name so she was born a loki named loki
but then later changed her name to sylvie because
she didn't want to be associated with the identity
of loki just because as bad as r loki's upbringing
was very similar to the main version of loki that
died during infinity war when silvia explains what
happened to her when she was growing up it sounds
even worse so up to their early childhood their
lives were pretty similar it's just that she was
born a woman instead of being born a man then at
some point in her childhood her version of frigga
died they don't explain how she died just that
she did die and because so much of the good that's
inside the loki character comes from frigga like
someone who believed in him taught him magic this
very gentle caring motherly figure in his life
sylvie didn't have that growing up so it kind of
explains why she's so much edgier than our version
of loki so imagine that odin for most of his life
was actually a pretty terrible dad imagine the
darkest timeline version of that that's who silvi
grew up with but otherwise most of their life
is fairly similar so that's why it's so easy for
each one of them to sort of peg each other from
the start like silly calls them out right at the
beginning saying you have no idea what you want
when he's sort of calling out her plan to just
completely destroy the tva and the time keepers
that also kind of confirmed my theory about
what her actual plan was basically kill the time
keepers and destroy the tva burn it to the ground
as loki said during episode one i'm going to burn
this place to the ground well technically he's not
wrong if you're talking about the alternate female
version of loki here or loki is still kind of in
that mode where he's thirsty for the throne like
he wants the throne of asgard so bad mobius was
joking about that during episode one too saying
what would happen if you got the throne would you
become king of space what would you do if you were
king of space and he has no answer for him because
he hasn't thought it through silly completely
calls them out on that too you have no idea what
you want they answer the question what makes a
real loki independence authority and style which
i feel like is a callback to the fine asgardian
leather joke from episode one rich corinthian
leather and when they were inside the rocks cart
him saying well usually i'd be wearing a suit when
they were trying to find sylvie for the first time
silly makes a verbal reference to annihilation
when they're walking to the next town which is yet
another annihilation conquest storyline reference
i know a lot of people wondering if they're ever
going to do annihilus in the marvel movies maybe
during some space based movie at some point they
have a bit of a moment when she tries and fails
to enchant him there are a couple moments like
this during the episode too like wait a minute
are they going to kiss what's going on here are
they actually going to do the homelander scene
from the boys season 2 the head writer for loki
before he actually got the job actually wrote this
story about this time traveler who was a fugitive
in the person who was chasing him through time and
they basically wind up falling in love so post all
your jokes about loki getting it on with himself
i don't actually think that that's going to happen
during the series i don't think that marvel would
take it to that place kevin feige would probably
pump the brakes before they got that far like
wait a minute we're not doing loki as a hentai
series there's the big joke with them both getting
their asses handed to them by the settler because
they're different plans neither one of them works
it's all meant to foreshadow them working together
in the episode in order to win like neither one of
them can do this by themselves using their
own tactics they both have to work together
in order to survive that's also probably going to
be more foreshadowing for what happens later in
the season too then they work together using both
of their abilities to make it past the guards onto
the train i did love the really terrible terrible
acting that loki was doing in the episode he went
full tropic thunder in this episode i'm
the dude playing the dude pretending to be
another dude but this whole thing with the tickets
in the train is meant to be a big indiana jones
in the last crusade reference tickets no tickets
then even though it's kind of inconsequential to
the overarching plot of the entire series like the
big narrative i love all the new details that they
reveal about their characters like loki reveals
that he can never sit backwards on a train sylvie
also because she's a loki and they're very similar
says i can't sit with my back to a door but she's
being just as ridiculous as he is because as he
says there are doors on both sides so no matter
where she sits she has her back to a door so it's
just the idea that they're both insufferable as
you would expect a loki to be when she yells about
him having only a fraction of a plan that's a call
back to guardians of the galaxy with peter quill's
12 of a planned speech they have their big bonding
moment over friga in magic just in general
with loki remembering all these details about
his childhood like i said one of the big points
where their lives diverged was when her version
of frigga died when she was a child but the title
of the episode lamentus in addition to being the
name of the planet that they're on the big marvel
reference like i said it's also the latin verb for
lamenting so loki is sort of lamenting the
death of friga during this scene they have
the joke about them being adopted loki says is
that a bit of a spoiler for you then she claims
that they told her when she was a child and when
loki says oh you know i found out eventually he's
referencing the events of the first thor movie
when he was trying to usurp the throne and disable
odin forcing him into the odin's sleep i love the
way he brushes over that event pretty quickly like
oh you know i found out eventually didn't tell her
under what circumstances he found out when loki
mentions friga showing him how to make fireworks
over the water that's obviously a setup for the
fireworks scene on the train later but it's also
a reference to the fireworks over her funeral ship
from thor the dark world and when he says turning
flowers into a frog that's also a reference to the
joke that thor told about the time that loki
turned him into a frog when they were younger
during thor ragnarok which itself was a frog thor
reference i love the way that loki pulls a thor
and gets super drunk the way you would expect
thor to do madam i am not drunk i am full it's
just that i am very very full he also makes a joke
about the candy that he drops on the floor later
that's a bit of a callback to the joke that moby
has told about there being no candy on asgard
like while we had grapes nuts no wonder you're so
bitter they have this big conversation about love
and lovers that they've had in the past big love
interests sylvie claims that she does have a lover
waiting for her and has been maintaining
a quote-unquote metaphorical and literal
long-distance relationship because of how far
across time she's been jumping during her big
plan here loki references a male lover like a bow
she doesn't correct him saying that it's a postman
i'm thinking they're probably going to pay that
off before the end of the series then when sylvie
asks if loki has ever had any romances this is
also a big reveal because in the marvel movies
they haven't really dug too deep into this but if
your big loki fan especially of real world norse
mythology a lot of the conversation they have here
too talking about the lovers that they've had is
accurate to real world mythology silvie says have
there been any princesses or even a prince in your
life before loki says a bit of both then says
he suspects the same of sylvie that's another
reference to loki's gender hopping and flew his
sexuality like on his tva file it says gender
fluid in real world norse mythology loki jumps
backwards and forth between male and female forms
all the time in fact if you know odin's six-legged
horse here that's right out of norse mythology but
in norse mythology loki changed himself into a
horse to mate with another horse and give birth
to the six-legged horse so loki himself sired
the six-legged horse so when they both talk
about having male and female relationships both
of them that's accurate to real world mythology
but it's all set up for them just never having
found true love and loki makes this big metaphor
later with a dagger like he tries to explain
love is a dagger but ultimately when you try
to grasp it it's not real maybe they'll pay
that off by the end of the series as well too
it was super fun watching him get just rip roaring
drunk singing those asgardian songs like this is
a pure thor moment right here he even smashes his
goblet and says another just like thor during the
events of the first thor film you also notice that
when he gets really drunk his magic wears off too
like he has to focus to keep his enchantment up
and i love some of the small moments that they
have here too like for just a hot second he really
wants to eat that candy off the floor like oh it's
terrible to let that go to waste but once they
have their big indiana jones last crusade moment
like where are your tickets oh here are tickets
right here and then they erupt into the fight
he even boots one of the guards out the window
just like indiana jones did but you do notice that
both of them have very similar fighting techniques
even though he has the twin daggers and still be
fights with a really large knife they both wind up
going out the window loki breaks the portal device
beyond repair so that's the end of the mcguffin
and even though you think they hit rock bottom
here i feel like the end of the episode is them
truly hitting rock bottom because it's like all
hope is lost as the ark is destroyed but i do
love the way that they joke about being a hedis
like loki says i'm a hedonist i make no apologies
for that silly claims she's way more hedonistic
than he is but she just never lets it get in the
way of her mission she's so focused on taking out
the time keepers love a lot of these conversations
that they have during the episode this is some of
my favorite stuff from the series so far then loki
gets her to start talking about herself more and
she explains how enchantment works about how she
has to create the fantasy illusion using people's
memories in how it works on some people but not as
good on others just depending on how strong their
minds are it is all set up for the reveal that
all the tva people are variants and they just
don't realize it because the time keepers are
altering their memories somehow which is just
playing into the idea that they're super sinister
and that's what hunter c20 was talking about when
she said it's real it's real she wanted to go home
she wants to go back to her version of earth that
the tva took her from when she was created in
a nexus event doing something they don't reveal
what it was she did to create the nexus event only
that she had a similar arc to our loki like she
created a nexus event and they said hey we can
either disintegrate you or you can work for us
and then at some point they just wiped her mind
so she forgot that she was a variant but the town
with the ark that they traveled to actually has
this very post-apocalyptic blade runner vibe to
it mixed with the design language from say like
nowhere or contraxia that pleasure planet from
guardians of the galaxy too the director did say
that the blade runner movie heavily inspired the
series in a number of different ways but like i
said there's cree language signage writing and
graffiti all over these walls so let me know if
you could decode any easter eggs here for those of
you that can read cree language then as the moon
finally breaks apart at its equator it almost kind
of looks like a giant pac-man face opening up
to eat them which you could think of is another
reference to ego the living planet like a planet
with a face and then also peter quill forming
himself into a giant pac-man during that same
movie like a giant pac-man moon is going to eat
this planet it's actually a pretty great disaster
scene which is everything crashing down around
them as they run and dodge things and fight off
some of these other guards these random people
loki saves sylvie a number of different times then
uses his magic to repel a giant piece of building
people were wondering what was going on here
like does loki have telekinesis he's not using
telekinesis this is magic that he's using it's
just that he's not giving off any magical energy
when it's happening but it's just another example
of him showing you how powerful his magic is like
he is very powerful and several times during
the episode sylvie kind of acknowledges that
then just as it seems like they're about to
make it to the ark it gets destroyed by a giant
meteorite and there's some sad guitar music starts
playing it's very on the nose talking about a dark
moon high up in the sky the song itself is called
dark sky and it's a 1959 cover by gail storm
which also you could think of as being very on the
nose the name of the singer because gale storm is
also what you would call apocalyptic weather and
they're in the middle of an apocalyptic event
unfolding on the planet right here and the song
itself is also about love which is another call
back to their conversation about love earlier in
the episode all the music choices on loki have
been amazing so far the original music like the
theme music they've done and also the licensed
music that they've used then if you watch all the
credits you'll actually notice that the credits
are different for every single episode they always
change a couple minor things this time the big
difference in the credits the new thing is that
you see a bunch of new pictures of loki and sylvie
together like snapshots depicting the events of
the episode as if someone is watching them and
making all these files there were also a couple
characters in the credits that were listed as
corporal hicks in private hudson which i believe
is an aliens reference there's a lot of different
sci-fi references to movies and television
shows baked into the loki series just in general
but if you spotted any other big easter eggs in
the episode that i didn't talk about during the
video just write them below in the comments
but what will happen is i'll do an episode 4
trailer video next and then i've got some more
rick and morty that's coming soon rick and
morty episodes are also running right now michael
waldron the showrunner on the loki series actually
came directly from rick and morty to do the loki
episodes so this is really weird crossover energy
between marvel and rick and morty right now dan
harmon was joking about marvel stealing all the
writers from his show links for those episodes
down in the description below too if you haven't
seen my rick and morty episodes will you wait for
everything everyone click here to learn how loki
just set up the events of spiderman no way home
and doctor strange 2 and click here for all my
full loki episodes thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!